dr michael shermer
hey that word doctor i don't know if we
can use that anymore now
i do have a phd not an edd but it's not
an md
and i don't want to be called kiddo in
the wall street journal
uh in case this is an evergreen and
people listen to this years from now
you'll know what i
idea what i'm talking about but dr jill
biden
joe president joe biden's wife is not a
md doctor
she's a edd doctor and anyway uh
this this became a flap this week for
some peculiar reason
the new cycle was not slow so i don't
know
i love how we've done this now
twice basically once in 2018 once in
2019 and now
again in 2020 we're doing this yeah i
thought we answered all the great
questions
there's more we did we did a lot of good
we did a lot of questions
we uh we did scientific humanism was the
first
episode and then we did an episode on
skepticism of
spirituality which was really
interesting and
now we're going to be doing an episode a
lot
on the synthesis of science and
spirituality and
some of the other themes i mean you
wrote a book giving the devil his due
which is now
what is this almost it's approaching six
over six months of
uh out uh that's right yes yes it
came out the week the world shut down so
yes not a good time to have a new book
out
well maybe people at home at home you
know actually um
book sales i was reading uh the book
industry trade
magazine the other day and book sales
have actually gone up
uh it's shifted around a little bit more
audio but the audio
sales have been cannibalizing from the
print sales print sales obviously have
gone down because bookstores closed but
the
e-book sales have also gone up and so it
appears people are reading more so
that's not such a bad thing
right uh content consumption has gone
up in oh yeah in podcast world too yeah
most podcast numbers
have gone sky high through the pandemic
so you know what people are doing
they're you know trying they're
multitasking they're
they're out working out or vacuuming the
house or whatever listening to content
which is
fantastic yeah that we have this
technology
and it's so cheap and in most cases just
free you know but most podcasts are free
you can get tons of college courses for
free i love that i mean you could take
just think about this for a second in
terms of the future of education you
know harvard charges
i don't know what is 60 000 a year right
you can get steve pinker's
course on rationality for free it's
online
and uh you know so that's you know why
would parents want to pay
that much money when you know the
knowledge exchange between professor and
student
is so cheap and and effective
and efficient to do right so that you
know the question is what what are you
getting for that well of course there's
in-class conversations that are hard to
replicate on zoom and
um you know the dorm life the social
life i know that's all fun
but really at 60 000 a year
yeah we have several friends that are in
the process of paying
three thousand dollars a month in
student loans right now and
we also know that the future of
education has a lot to do with the
democratization of information
technology into these
augmented and virtual reality landscapes
where they can really intake
content there's the neuralink phenomenon
that's emerging as well with bio and
neuro
synthesis which is super exciting you
know last time we talked i thought this
was so
interesting that when
i had just finished mama nuiwan
who's a kogi elder of the
uh sierra nevada de santo marta
in colombia and i just finished a couple
day
retreat wow just sitting with the kogi
elder
and they have a multi-thousand-year
lineage in that area
unbroken and it was really nice because
we did our interview right after i had
sat
with the kogi elder that was the second
one we did
and in this last year there has been a
lot
that's unfolded around well
obviously i published high-level
perception a synthesis of
the nature of consciousness reality
maximizing human potential science and
spirituality
and some of the
ways of dialectic between us i feel is
gonna
be upgraded and so i'm curious to
explore on like a very
first principled level
and you can tell me if you think this
isn't even the most first principled
question
maybe we start with that do you think
that the question
why does reality exist is that the most
first principled question that may be
one thought too many
as thomas nagel says you know it's it
um it may be almost a meaningless
question
uh it just is reality just is it's it's
almost like
asking um you know what what
what it's like to to be dead or what
imagine there's no universe nothing no
space or time or stuff
no concepts no platonic ideas just
nothing
well at some point you can't even
conceive of it because to conceive of
something
you have to exist right so i i i have a
sense that you've we
that question bumps up against an
epistemological wall
and you know i'm not a philosopher but
you know philosophers may have some term
that that's a
you know an error in category
questions or something like this i'm not
sure what what it would be called but
just the way you phrased it phrase
phrase it again
the question why does reality why does
reality exist right
um you know simon cynic has start with
why
right yeah and it's just an interesting
question if we start with our own
individual personal why why what is my
purpose what is my north star
what is why am i doing what i'm doing
but then we also ask the same question
about reality itself i mean one answer
is why not
i mean it's just why is there something
rather than nothing well why not flip it
around
why would there be nothing instead of
something maybe something is the natural
state of things it's just the way it is
and the nothing would be difficult to
explain
so again i mean you you just want to
take us back to the beginning well what
if
we mentioned off air roger penrose
cyclical universes
what if there is no beginning it's just
an infinity of cycles that goes all the
way back
and and that information is gone so we
can never know it
let's say so okay so then then what then
we kind of well
well that's actually a massive paradigm
change because
exist the existing structures
uh of the last we can say maybe several
hundred years
have been a very physicalism-oriented
structure system that's been very driven
by the linearity of time
and which is somewhat different actually
significantly different than what
most of the ancient perennial spiritual
mystic traditions talk about
but now when you have people like siraj
penrose who won the nobel prize in
physics in 2020
who step up and ha he has a conformal
cyclic cosmology theory
and so now if we're literally talking
about the world's
most cutting edge scientists
in physics are beginning to
put us beyond in
our hypotheses about what exists
pre big bang and beyond where we're
going yeah
yeah that's a really important
conversation because
it changes our paradigm from being
linear and finite
to being eternal and infinite is that
well but
but but the idea of the universe being
eternal and
infinite is not new you know that's been
around forever
uh that's always been a possibility it's
just that
in science there's got to be some way to
get at it to test it
to run an experiment to decide if your
idea that it's cyclical
and non-linear and my idea that it's
finite and linear uh
which one is right and and if there's
never
even in principle any way we can answer
it then what are we talking about
you know we're just we're just kind of
navel gazing for fun
which is fun but um you know for me i'm
more of a pragmatist what difference
does it make in terms if we can't answer
it
what are we talking about why are we
even talking about it is it that have to
do with
how you personally find meaning and
purpose in life do you need to know
whether it's linear or cyclical infinite
or finite
or um or not i mean
i don't personally it doesn't matter to
me in terms of what i do tomorrow
or you know the rest of my life or or
whatever it's interesting to know
except although part of my life is
is addressing theists arguments about
god's existence or not and
then they of course push this argument
that there has to be a first cause
because
if you go back in time there cannot you
know there cannot be
no first cause because there's cause and
effects all the way up to
right now so what's the first cause or
who's the first cause and so on
so i am interested in in a way of like
well how would you answer that question
uh and so you know what we're talking
about is maybe a way of kind of say well
your idea that god is the first cause
the prime mover
is not the only idea in the category and
then i would return to what i just said
and and if there's no way we can test
whether the christian model or the
secular cosmology model is the right one
then at some point we just throw our
hands up and talk about something else
this in many ways appears to be where
we're heading which is the
synthesis of science and spirituality
and technology to run simulations and
prove more and more what is the nature
of our existence and it is in many ways
the most first principled question
and we're becoming more and more awake
and aware to
our methods of being able to inquire the
in a sense the veil is being pierced
and we're able to understand our own
existence better
and that's a very beautiful part of our
what can be viewed as uh in that cycle
it appears to be us in our later
potential stages of
of said cycle now there are certain yes
schools of thinking like you know when
even leo tolstoy
saying the kingdom of god is within you
even the word god is now so
loaded and packed with different regions
of the world believing
certain at things it's like big nice
word clouds
around each god for every single
uh as descriptors for what they believe
that that that is
and then there's this sort of in what
i've what i've experienced now is a more
perennial wisdom around what god
means and
it appears to be that our
awareness pre-coloration
just our being our is-ness
as much as i know that you've had many
conversations with deepak chopra and
that you've had many conversations that
are trying to sort of
ground the spiritual community i think
that's extremely important
it's also important to in a sense let
spirituality
try to push the edge of what science
knows and have science come and test it
with
the scientific method along the way so
in the sense it is the very fact that we
are conscious and we are aware
and we are experiencing this right now
that phenomenon itself and this just
one you being one expression of that
potential infinite creation that's
occurring
and this just being one combination of
it and us experiencing it
it's uh that appears to be close to what
the perennial spiritual traditions are
indicating and even science is now
trying to validate
maybe i'm not i'm not 100 sure i know
where you're going with this so
um you know a couple essays in my
my latest book giving the devil is due
one is on
why is there something rather than
nothing so i mean i don't know the
answer to it no one knows so i just
basically cataloged the dozen or so
answers that people give
uh dismissing starting by dismissing the
theological arguments that's one but
but again if they're not testable you
know what are we talking about how can
we get at it so
the ones i present are the scientific
ones so there's different ones so you've
kind of hinted at
some of that but then there's um how to
what's the purpose of life well
here i have a section called alvey's
error
this was one of my scientific american
columns alvey is alvi
singer woody allen's character in annie
hall
when he has a flashback to it as a child
and his mother takes him to the
psychiatrist because he won't do his
homework
and the psychiatrist says why won't you
do your homework alby and he says
because the universe is expanding
he says the universe is expanding yes
it's expanding and one day it's just
gonna all
blow apart and none of this is gonna be
around
so why bother to do my homework none of
this matters
and his mother's you know kind of
upgrades him and says what's the
universe got to do with it we live in
brooklyn and brooklyn's not expanding
right so this is what you know
philosophers call a category error that
you know
talking about like if if my actions
today
don't make any difference 14 billion
years from now
then they don't matter yes they matter
not 14 billion years from now but now
you know because we don't live in the
so that's my argument to the theist
argument about the
necessity for having an afterlife why we
don't live in the afterlife we live in
this life
we don't live in the hereafter we live
in the here and now and what you do
now matters to other people
um you know and so you know it's like
this william lake craig made this
argument that
um you know if there's no god and
there's no afterlife and
it's just this um you know heat death of
the universe in billions of years from
now
then it didn't matter that what the
nazis did to the jews
it doesn't ultimately cosmically matter
and it's like that's a category error it
matters to the jews
at that time when they're being uh
you know exterminated it matters to them
and it matters to us
now because we we don't want this to
happen again
so that more people suffer and and so
forth
so all of this is super interesting um
but for me
spirituality has a more pragmatic uh
element to it that is how does it affect
my life now
what difference does it make so if you
know if you tell me well being
a spiritual person whatever that may
mean meditating
giving thoughtful reflections on your
relationships and
your friendships and what you're doing
with your life those are wonderful
things
so those are all really good things but
but but
they have measurable effects right they
lower blood pressure they reduce stress
they put the little things that irritate
people
uh into perspective so you're not
irritated by them they help
attenuate thought flooding that
meditation people
always talk about you know you just have
this flood of thoughts of
what your boss said and that co-worker
and you pisses me off and you rehearse
it in your mind
this is what i should have said you know
you could do this for an hour
it won't make any difference at all and
it's probably elevated your
uh stress hormones and you know broken
your telomeres a little bit shorten your
life by a few minutes or whatever
you know so there i i can see okay that
has a good
measurable effect and this is why it's
good to be a spiritual
person but i have a feeling you're after
something deeper than that like
something cosmically
significant or well let's unpack some of
this more that was a good
tennis ball hit back so there's this
phrase that i think is really important
it's simultaneity simultaneous key
and so it really kind of boils down to
when we were talking a couple minutes
ago it was
why do why do things have to be either
or where we talk about having
a biological finite linear
80-year lifespan while simultaneously
holding an infinite eternal
cyclic cosmological
simultaneously because when you begin
holding those two things at the same
time
you realize that yeah i do actually care
a lot about my moment to moment
in terms of identifying how can i
how can i be more peaceful how can i be
more happy how can i be more blissful
how can i understand the nature of my
existence and the
what gifts i'm bringing to the world how
can i actualize those gifts how can i
bring value to my
myself my family community in the world
at large
and then in a sense we merge that
self-actualized tendency with a
self-realization tendency
which is talked about as something like
realizing
what god is realizing what conscious
what role consciousness plays in
realities
and when we sort of merge those things
together it
really locks in a strong
moment to moment-to-moment presence that
is transcendent
and present and just incredibly
beautiful to
vibe with on a person-to-person
level yeah i do agree that having a
cosmic perspective
on things deep time uh deep space
the darwinian evolutionary model the
cosmological model
it's 14 billion years it's not 6 000
years
uh you know it's not just us in a little
solar system you know we're just a
you know a pale blue dot as carl like to
say
uh you know and you know one of a
hundred billion
stars and probably a trillion planets in
our galaxy alone
you know and 100 billion to a trillion
galaxies and on and on
it does put things into perspective and
and helps you realize that
uh you know the trivial small things in
life don't really matter
uh you know it's the it's the deeper
more important things that we do
that matter more um you know all that
matters i mean
just if you think about you know the
kind of history of science and the
changing world views
from the medieval worldview to the
modern world view does make a difference
on how we
treat other people how we treat the
planet limited resources
so forth you know all that matters yes
it does
um and this actually plays into the
second thing that i was
going to say which was you're spot on as
well that
the realization of infinity eternity
does not
need to make the existing life that we
find ourselves in as an expression
of that potential infinity or eternity
as something that is
nihilistic or meaningless rather be
viewing it
as something that is an artistic
expression something that is
something beautiful something that is
that you as an individual in that
get to contribute something unique in
and so in this case it would be like you
listed there are these
atrocities that happen around the world
where millions of people
encounter levels of suffering and death
and malevolence that are horrid and so
we've
understood now that we want to move our
society and civilization away
from suffering malevolence tyranny
murder and we want to move it towards
maximizing well-being
prosperity and this is the classic
heaven hell analysis
as jordan peterson talked to sam harris
about in with brett weinstein and all
those fireside chats with douglas murray
that they had
they're fantastic conversations but it
is quite true that
the the way the portrayal that jordan
says of hell
and heaven is very similar to sam
harris's portrayal of
suffering and well-being and so
ultimately we
are working our way more and more
towards
what we hope to be prosperity abundance
uh i'm actualizing everyone's fullest
potential yeah
and so we've identified that as
something that we care about
um unfortunately a lot of religious
people don't think of it as a metaphor
like maybe hopefully that's what jordan
means when he talks about that
you know kind of mythic truths or
metaphorical truths about
heaven and hell a lot of christians for
example
and muslims you know think this is
actually a place you go to
you know after you die that your soul
floats off your brain and goes off into
the ether
through the quantum fields or whatever
they they think it does
um you know that then we're not that's a
completely different subject really it's
what the way you're phrasing it and and
hopefully that's what jordan means when
he says that although i'm never 100
sure about that uh you know that
that can lead to a humanist kind of you
know enlightenment humanist or
scientific humanist worldview
in which we recognize the suffering of
other creatures in part having a cosmic
perspective an evolutionary
perspective like your shirt you know
we're all you know we're all
you know share dna with the tree right
yeah and yeah
and uh you know sagan used to say that
you know there was a better chance that
we could breed with a petunia
on earth than than an alien you know
just because they're not going to have
dna probably and
anyway so this in response to this idea
of alien human hybrids you know
living amongst us whatever uh having
some
scientific perspective on things cleans
out a lot of the garbage that's out
there
and i do think that the idea of literal
heaven and hell
is garbage it's not not only is it not
true but it's harmful
to people and it takes away from the
recognition of other creatures
as possibly suffering you know as jeremy
bentham famously articulated
before there was an animal rights uh
movement that you know it isn't can they
talk or can they
think it's can they suffer you know so
the suffering of
sentient beings uh is uh kind of a moral
starting point
and having a you know a scientific world
view enables that and not
having that uh may not uh
enhance that the suffering of sentience
is a moral starting yeah i think so yeah
and i think you say that in the moral
arc yeah you got to start somewhere
right
but that's a good place to start you
don't have to start with some cosmic
significance or or
a deity uh or some holy book just start
with you know
can other sentient beings suffer and
what should i do to
you know attenuate that that's a good
starting point yeah
yeah and really it is the grounding of
most of the modern
uh ethical systems i agree uh
that is you know when you talk about
utilitarianism or
deontological you know kind of
rule-based morals or
aristotle's virtue ethics it all seems
to have something to do with
how other people are affected uh by your
actions
and to what extent the rules that you're
employing
it does affect us you know so it's very
consequential
even the ethical systems that claim not
to be consequential
well the consequences have to be in the
formula somewhere if you're
a person living on a desert island by
yourself there's no morals there's no
ethics
except for maybe eating animals or
something like that um so
yeah so i mean these are deep you know
questions like where you began
you know where do you start well you
have to start somewhere so i reference
thomas nagel's you know one thought too
many
you know he he he brings this up in in
terms of like
explaining consciousness at some point
you know it it may just be a starting
point
consciousness it just is and
if you try to answer the hard question
of consciousness that is the
qualitative experience of what it means
to be
something you know that
it may be a problem a conceptual problem
namely
a problem with our concepts and language
we use to talk about these things
in a way because i can never know
really what you experience in your head
and
just the asking of the question kind of
implies that
there's a homunculus in me and there's
one in you and
my little homunculus can uh tiptoe out
of my head into your head to see if the
red looks like
uh my red on the cartesian theater of
your mind
you know of course this is all
ridiculous we can't do anything like
that
and uh so how do we address that problem
of you know other minds well here's
again a good starting point the
copernican principle
which states i'm not special we're not
special right
the original copernican principle um
we're not the center of the universe
we're not even the center you know at
the center of the galaxy we're not
the center of anything we're not special
so
uh if i know that your brain
uh you're a mammal and why can't
everything be special
it's something important to ask the
simultaneity being key principle
so there are different levels okay of
course everybody is special
but what i mean is is there nothing
special about my brain
so if i suffer pain and i see you
exhibiting
the behaviors of suffering pain you're
writhing on the ground you're moaning
and groaning
i can predict even though i can't really
know what your mind is like you know the
other mind problem maybe you're just a
zombie and there's
the lights are out and and you just
appear to be
a sentient conscious being but you're
not the copernican principle tells me
you are
really yeah let's let's unpack these
these levels so
let's start with let's start with this
which was a moment ago which
is great which is something along the
lines of
where sentience suffers
is our moral starting point so
that's a great way to sort of begin in a
scientific humanistic utilitarian
rational also spiritual way
to begin understanding where the mystic
traditions have been trying to eradicate
suffering as well as
you know science driving poverty out of
the planet and driving
abundance in which is fantastic what you
how you define spirituality or what do
you mean by that
well it's a good question and i thought
that it would also be interesting to
highlight to you this as we talk
and it's a good way to kind of segue us
also into the answer of that
that question which is you know this
this illustration that is in
chapter 7 of high-level perception
it's called the sorting algorithm and
it's actually
highly inspired by
jordan peterson sam harris's fireside
chats
and because in general what this graphic
is trying to represent
is that you it's the old
saying that goes don't drain the baby
with the dirty bath water
and so you want to uplift the baby and
in this case the one on the left can be
something like
let's say spirituality you want to drain
the dirty bath water
of spirituality which has a lot to do
with dogmas and fundamentalism and
basically the things that michael has
been
beating down uh throughout his uh and
many others really have been doing so
and sam has and it's been very very
important
and for maximizing prosperity
but we keep the spiritual baby which
we'll address here in a moment and then
on the
on the let's say on this on the right
side of the graphic
is something like science and so with
science we have a lot of perverse
incentives
in the scientific academia we saw this
with the skull
affair and we also saw it again with the
the most recent uh what was james
lindsay's and
peter bogosians called again uh you you
mean their
their hosts what were their hoax papers
just generally hoaxed papers
so grievance grievance studies studies
okay so then we had it we had it show up
twice those perverse incentives plus we
have a lot of other bad
incentives like for example i can just
take you on a another
example with the draining the dirty
bathwater of science but
when you look at like around 1945 or so
and you just begin sort of thinking
about like
if if scientists and engineers
that had maybe a little bit more of an
understanding of
you know like sentience is suffering
right
would we make nuclear weapons would we
drop them
on hiroshima nagasaki and then similarly
i know there's a lot of to unpack even
just there but i'll just i'll just
finish the rift quickly
and so there's the dirty bath water in
science
and then there's the beautiful
scientific method which is the baby
in you know pushing beyond the edge of
what civilization knows planting flags
making hypotheses testing them with the
scientific methods fantastic
and so in a sense it's the merging of
science and spirituality
into one that is going to enable the
most
abundant prosperity that we've ever
experienced in the
21st century in my perspective and that
looks
something like also
this graphic which this is
in this one is in chapter six called ai
coach but this one specifically called
the biometrics of awakening
and this is very scientifically literate
because basically the idea is that we
constantly put
civilization in a wealth hierarchy of
the eight billion people
and we say okay there's twenty two
hundred billionaires
and then there's a billion or more
people that are in international poverty
of less than two us dollars a day
there's some sort of spectrum in between
but we never put up like an
enlightenment hierarchy
next to that and we wonder well what
does it mean what does non-duality mean
and this might answer some of your
questions about what i think
spirituality is
what does it mean to you know to feel
non-duality what does it mean to feel
one with everything what does that mean
and then where would potentially be
some of the scientific ways that can
validate
states of potentially beyond egoic
levels of consciousness
so you can kind of tell when somebody
has that vibe
where they're very egoic and
self-dealing and they're trying to get
themselves things versus when somebody's
really in service to other people when
somebody is really trying to
you know maybe they do understand some
of those those further transpersonal
non-dual levels of existence
and science comes in in a great way here
because it basically has
technologies like fmri eeg
near infrared spectrometry they have
uh all of the studies with heart rate
variability and heart math
they have all the incredible studies
that are going on with the gut
microbiome
and you can sort of begin telling like
when are people living in coherent
brainwave frequencies when are people
have
higher heart rate variability so it's
not this lower more stressed
stationary heart rate and so
these are good ways to sort of begin in
a sense getting us to a place of
okay well maybe science can actually
help us quantify
more enlightened states of being how do
you feel about this yeah that's what
that's what deepak has been trying to do
with meditation
and his interest in science and i wrote
about this in
heavens on earth i had a chapter talking
about
going to his um center the chopra center
in carlsbad
and what that was like how you know it
was wonderful it was great
and you know beachside resort getting
massages and meditating
and doing yoga and eating great food and
you know green tea and working out every
day yeah i mean
if you don't feel better after that you
know there's something wrong with you
really bad there's nothing wrong with
with all that
uh but what he's after more than that is
is this difference between does it work
for me versus does it really work
so if i say well meditation works for me
it makes me feel better
uh okay good uh but but what people like
deepak want to know what want to do is
they want to say it actually really
works
well what do we mean by work well it
makes people feel better other people
not just me
well which other people all people 90 of
people
you know and and we're looking for some
equation like well
you know 75 of people who participated
in this
study who did two hours of meditation
per day
you know and controlled for everything
else forget the massages and the green
tea and
and all that because you got to take
those out of the equation if you want to
know
what you're measuring the dependent
variable in this case maybe it's
it's stress hormone levels and you draw
blood or it's you know your blood
pressure levels and you
you put the cuff on and you measure that
every hour you know some
something like that uh to show well does
it really work
you know and that that there you can
essentially write the equivalent of a
medical doctor's
uh a prescription i'm giving you this
prescription of you know one hour
meditation per
day five days a week uh and you know and
so on and so forth and then
you know then we start add in the other
variables you know you should exercise
you know 30 minutes a day you should
have these kind of diet this kind of
diet versus that kind of diet
you know and so on you add it all up now
if that's what you mean by
integrating science and spirituality yep
yeah that
that's a good paradigm yeah and i think
that you know not i'd mentioned deepak
but you know there's other people doing
this yeah
as well you know there's a there's a lot
of labs there's a pretty good
great body of scientific literature
studying ions is doing it heart math is
doing it
then there's uh so many other
um centers that are actually even trying
to get this down to the
level of where we're biohacking
our our um our states of awareness
and consciousness to the degree of which
[Music]
a lot of the technologies that we're
talking about are completely outside of
the mainstream
uh medical industrial complex because
in many ways pharma and insurance have
many perverse incentives with the system
that in a sense what you're describing
at deepak's
center is basically like that
that that should be a paradigm that can
be a paradigm
that's not just here take this ssri and
it'll help you take prozac
because it's something you have to take
daily but now if you
we just talked about this on the program
as well but now if you take
psilocybin and this is the work of
multidos
maps multidisciplinary association with
psychedelic studies if you take
enthiogens
what ends up happening is
within just one dose
there's less anxiety less depression no
fear of
death and there's a complete withdrawal
from use of prozac and
ssris and then you have a
pers you know the people that are
undergoing psilocybin are saying things
like
you know my journey on magic mushrooms
ranks in the
you know 33 percent of people say that
it ranks
in their is as their top most meaningful
experience and then
70 percent of people rank it in their
top five most meaningful experiences
and so you know to me because i've
undergone this i've undergone that yeah
i guess i should try that
i haven't done anything like this i'd
kind of like to do that
5mu dmt joe rogan has talked about this
on the program
a lot we have we have we have the proper
safe people to
walk people like you and others into
this place really the larger
uh program you're working on here is to
try to take the woo-woo
out of uh of spirituality and for good
reason because there's a lot of [ __ ]
in
in the in the new age movement um
you know the whole secret program and
you know if you just wish it'll happen
and
you know this kind of business um so i
appreciate that i mean in a way
it's a deeper philosophy of science
question about how do we get at the
truth
may i also just quickly because you that
that was the first example that you gave
but
now my my question would be have you
you're familiar with jordan peterson's
future authoring program
right i'm familiar with i haven't tried
it or read much on it and
and i have i've tried it and i've been
promoting it and
i'm just saying jordan peterson's future
authoring program
is not that much different than the idea
of
manifesting as the secret yes as long as
there's no
paranormal in there yeah yeah yeah and
as long as you set
an intention to achieve a goal but then
you also take those steps that are
needed
to actually get to your goals and so but
you're much more likely
if you wake up every day with the divine
noble transcendent north star aim what's
going to happen is you're going to have
a little bit more of that fire and flare
to
to take the steps that are needed to get
there versus if that doesn't exist if
there's no
future authorization absolutely of
course yeah but the universe doesn't
care about you
it doesn't because there's no universe
to care i mean in that sense
it's not the universe not conscious it's
not willing you to have a new tesla
model x
in your driveway tomorrow and then i
just wish it and there it is
you know it's not how it happens okay
but if you want to say
i'm setting that as my goal and in five
years i want to have that manifested in
my driveway
and i'm going to do this extra work and
save the money do some investments blah
blah blah
i have the money i write the check i get
the car boom okay yes of course
you know and and to that extent you know
i i think jordan
if that's what his program is you know
that's not so different from all the
self-help
programs you know from napoleon hills
think and grow rich
tony robbins tony robbins all this stuff
you know they they mostly steer away
from the
supernatural woo-woo paranormal stuff
and and
and just bring it down to what you do
and yes of course that works but you
know within limitations i can't just say
well i you know i want to be an nba
basketball player you know i'm
five seven and i'm 66 years old it's not
going to happen
okay so you know you got to pick things
that you're good at that you can
actually do
and then aim for them you know so let's
let's uh
let's let's show you another example
what what you talk about here is wait
you still haven't told me what you
like so what you mean by spiritual i'm
giving you examples
but i want a sentence so you're on let's
say you're on a date and your date says
are you a spiritual guy
you know you're on a first date and she
wants to know are you the elevator pitch
yeah the elevator pitch yes of course
i'm a spiritual person and they go well
what do you mean by that
because they want to know do you mean
that you're a christian you're a
buddhist you're a jew you're this
i would say that's the first in a sense
like fundamental
step that is slowly becoming more and
more
uh realized as it's just something that
gets people
ready for something that's even more uh
truly spiritual religion
in many ways is in some ways just
a baby step towards something that's
even more
yeah okay and so and people are
realizing there's a lot of perverse
incentives
in religious structures across the
planet
but you know every single one of the
religious traditions actually has
a mystic tradition every single one of
them does
and so whether we're talking about for
for um for hinduism it's things like
advaita vedanta
or in buddhism it's zen and zokchen or
the um the islamic tradition
is called the sufi metaphysics then
there's um
there's there's uh cidism and cabalism
and gnosticism in the jude the the
judeo-christians and then there's also
there's these like african vodon
traditions around actually dancing and
becoming
gods then there's the native americans
north and south that are about you know
sweat lodges there's entheogens
there's potlatches there's all these
styles of representation there
so what so after studying this landscape
which i think in many ways jordan
peterson has done as well
and there are others that have done this
as well as spiritual synthesis
is what you realize is that all of those
mystic
traditions right so specifically the
mystic ones not
the religious fundamentalism ones
so those mystic ones are basically
different flavors of ice cream
so one of them's chocolate the other is
vanilla the other strawberry the other
is mango and you just keep going down
the line
but what they all have in common the
perennial spiritual wisdom
is that they're is the third is that
they're all
ice cream yeah that's what they have in
common yeah okay i get that i see where
you're going
okay yeah and then and and great i'm
glad and then and so then
now if we look at it at that at that ice
cream level now the question would be
you know when you're asked like what
does it mean and so i've gotten to this
point and it's that okay these mystic
traditions
have the similarity it's like a meta
pattern
which is something along the lines of
that
but if i say if i ask you why do you
want to be a spiritual person
i mean because it makes me a better
person or i'm a moral or i
it puts my life into perspective or
so well you you gave we've both been
giving a lot of great answers to that
you know decreased cortisol levels
higher levels of future authoring
towards goals
um my my ability to be more peaceful
happy
loving compassionate eradicating
suffering in my goals
having great better relationships with
my family my friends there's definitely
hugely pragmatic
uh aspects to this yet at the same time
the answer might be something like when
you look at all of those different
the perennial spiritual ice cream itself
what is that
spiritual ice cream
a good way to potentially answer that
would be you know what does
the delphic maxim that was written on
the top
of the temple of apollo at delphi
2500 years ago two words
know thyself what does that mean what
does it mean
that question and so that what i
what i hypothesize again i'm totally
cool with calling his hypotheses i'm
totally cool with planting flags beyond
the edge and working our way with the
scientific method to prove these things
absolutely non-dogmatic whatsoever on
the program
what i would hypothesize as what know
thyself means
and this is what many of the perennial
spiritual traditions have hypothesized
that it means
is that it's twofold
it's self-realization and
self-actualization
and ultimately those are one but we'll
split them into two to explain it
so self-realization can be thought of
in many ways like what the sufi
metaphysics
called wahat al-wujud which is the unity
of all being in existence or what even
the scientific community today
is proving as well i guess
technically i take 20 000 inhales of
oxygen every single day
but that oxygen is coming from the
photosynthesis of phytoplankton and
trees
70 from the phytoplankton and so then
i wonder okay fine well technically then
yeah there is an interdependence
right and then you look at graphics like
this which i kind of had queued up for
this which is basically like you have
this person
that's maybe here on the left side of
the screen that has a more
porous they're more perforated
they understand that every single one of
their inhales and exhales is
interdependent on the planetary
photosynthesis
and they also realize that every single
one of the gulps of water that they're
drinking
is reliant on the hydro planetary
hydrological cycle that we're currently
polluting with epps environmentally
persistent pharmaceutical pollutants
and a lot of other things but it's the
same water that we're drinking that
dinosaurs drink 66 million years ago in
the hydrological cycle
and then you also think about things
like well what about these 1 000
species of gut bacteria that i have
inside of me that each have 2
000 gene expressions so if we're talking
two million total gene expressions which
is a hundred times the 20 000
approximate human gene expressions
we are really in some interesting
territories of what is the symbiotic
relationship that i have inside of me
and now if you juxtapose that with the
person that's on the right
if you look at the person that's on the
right the person that's on the right
has a red box around their head there's
no feelings of interconnectedness
there's no feelings of
interconnectedness with the bite of the
apple
and that undergoing the process of
cellular respiration with conversion of
of glucose to atp for energy and there's
no
interconnected feelings with the oxygen
they're inhaling and
exhaling co2 there's no
interconnectedness with the water or the
gut
and so this is just you know we call
this identity we call this porosity we
call this perforation
so in a way it's the
your level of self-realization has a lot
to do with your realization of the unity
of all being in existence
but also it has to do with your
understandings of what we were talking
about at the beginning regarding
this awareness or this consciousness
and its relation to infinite creation
and infinite eternal
exploration that it's undergoing
cyclically as we hypothesize
and so that would be self-realization
and then the self-actualization side
is what we were talking about regarding
future authoring or tony robbins
strategies
or any of these other ideas around
what's my you know self-help what
strategies do i need to
to take in order to achieve a divine
north star that brings value to the
world that i get financially rewarded
for
that's the most common phenomenon is
self-actualization
in the modern world but in the sort of
more indigenous world
there's a lot more proclivity towards
the uh self-realization and then that's
why this sort of synthesis of the two
into one is
ultimately i think what's most healthy
for where we're going wow
i think your date would be asking for
the check about now
waiter that's my elevator pitch
that's a long elevator ride yeah it's a
difficult time i want to break down into
just a couple no no i mean i i follow
that
i mean i think it's pretty much what i
said before about
having a cosmic perspective an
evolutionary perspective
uh having all the details you just went
through of
having some uh scientific knowledge
is actually good for a humanistic
perspective
so this is that you know that that uh
kind of division between the sciences
and the humanities
really they they go together and you
just give a perfect example of
of what that could bring to a humanistic
worldview
which previously mostly depended on
novels and literature
and and sources like poems and and
sources like that
for um understanding the human condition
i think in my opinion uh science offers
all that and more
you know because it's actually true uh
and that perspective then can change
your life that's why i always said you
know carl sagan i think
as a very spiritual person uh even
though he's an atheist
or at least an agnostic anyway and uh
and you know
a pure you know scientific humanist and
so on although i i would still
say he's as spiritual as any of the uh
the gurus you mentioned
or whatever you want to call them um
yeah so i i think that's that's fine but
again
at some point you got to get up and go
to work tomorrow right so
it's not like you can think about this
all of the time
i remember after reading uh eckhart
tolle's book the power of now
uh you know it's very it's a pretty good
book actually you know sort of puts
things into perspective
the past has already happened you can't
do anything about it so why
dwell on it and obsess about it and
worry about it the future hasn't
happened yet
uh we just live in the now so you know
that that's kind of
a an important reminder and it's like
yep
okay that's good but you know i gotta
pay my mortgage tomorrow
next month so i gotta go to work
tomorrow you know so it
pulls you back into the real world i i
see this is a little bit like what
religion
is for a lot of people which is you know
it's something you do on sundays or
whatever it's it's kind of a reminder
of what's important which is good but
it's not the kind of thing you can think
about
all the time can you maybe you do
but you know because it's it's
interesting the synthesis of the two
is what is potentially okay not only
right not only most
interesting but let's go back to you
know
talk about jordan peterson you know so
one of my essays in
giving the devil is do is you know have
archetype will travel
uh you know it's about jordan and uh you
know so
here i think we can distinguish between
um
different kinds of truths you know so if
i say
did the resurrection actually happen
uh and maybe jordan responds well
you know we all must bear our own cross
and that life is difficult
and you know jesus and the resurrect the
crucifixion and the resurrection
the born again starting over
suffering you know as literature
okay i get that you know it's kind of a
mythic truth
uh and it has meaning for
my life because i suffer and then i can
work through that suffering and start
over be born again
in a metaphorical way okay you know
that's what literature does that's what
myths do
for us but but what a scientist wants to
know is
but you christians claim that this
person jesus actually died and came back
to life
and that they will say absolutely that's
what we believe
and some of them yeah so most
you know otherwise there's no point in
being a christian right
the most of it hinges on that well
as it is an empirical effect
metaphorical truth which is what
they spent a good amount of time with
brett weinstein on stage talking about
this also with the revolver id is a
really good one if you treat
every single gun that you're given as
though it's loaded
even if it's not yeah is a good choice
to do
yeah and that's a good sort of way of
putting it like you're saying in this
essay the idea is like a metaphorical
truth that can be really helpful
and really insightful in the things that
we do but but in the same way
you know good literature um but when you
drain the bathwater of the dogma and the
fundamentalism of course
yeah there's core elements in most
literature that has to do with human
nature human relationships
you know the whole field of evolutionary
literature uh
it's sort of a branch of evolutionary
psychology you know why do certain
themes come up over and over and over in
in novels because they're the most
important things
in the human condition uh you know power
and hierarchy and deception
and love and jealousy and you know the
whole
thing it comes up over and over because
that's what's important to us
so uh there i would say you know you
know of course the jane austen novels
are not true
but they're true metaphorically because
they tap into
certain truths about who we are and what
we do
and what matters that kind of thing
another
way of putting what
self-realization is
thought of is
something that looks a little bit like
this
and this is a hypothesis about what the
nature of consciousness
is again a hypothesis and so the idea
being
you leverage something like calculus
in a synthesis of physicalism with
spirituality
you leverage calculus to help people
understand the integral the integration
of
infinitesimal data aka the
8 billion humans on the planet
but then there's this unique
differentiation
the derivative the individuation so
on a on a biological level it goes
something like 99.9 percent genetically
similar humans
the integral and then the 0.1
genetic difference is your unique north
star gift that you're bringing into the
world
and so that's where you can think of
like a self-realization being something
like the
integration the unity of all being in
existence and the self-actualization
being that unique
gift that you're bringing into the world
and i think that when we do things like
we aim to visualize these concepts which
is
a lot of what high-level perception did
is that
it sort of begins not only driving them
more into like explain lake i'm five
territory visualization territory
but it also it kind of hits on the point
that so many of the greatest logicians
of all time have been talking about and
even metaphysicians
the idea that you must make your ideas
very clear clear and precise enough so
that people can actually
take them apart if as you aim to plant
your flag beyond the edge of what we
know
we have to create the scientific
methodological processes that can
test it but also to sort of dismantle it
if it's incorrect
and whatnot so you have to say things
very precisely and i think
by doing these types of visuals it sort
of assists
even if it's in an elementary way the
process
okay and so that's why you see things
like pixar
if you know did you get a chance to see
the movie inside out
they spent a couple years making this
movie called inside out
and it's about the
the internal psychological
workings of the human and
it takes it from a very explain like i'm
five child like animated perspective
and so it teaches young kids that
there's these little characters that are
happening inside of them that are kind
of like peering through the screen and
like
the characters are like joy or anger or
frustration
or sadness and and that these characters
are pulling the switches and that
they're in these type of things
and so in a general way not that it's a
thousand percent scientific 100
scientifically
literate and accurate although they did
do a lot of scientific
consultation and making sure that it was
in many ways
that at least fundamentally we're trying
to
in a 90-minute animated movie
get kids to be more knowledgeable about
their inner workings
and so i think that this is the medium
of the future
the medium of the future is in my
opinion
no longer 300 pages
of text my opinion
and it's more of
having a significant amount of visuals
infographics diagrams
but that's only the
one step the next step is to sort of
make this type of content mathematically
manipulable
so meaning i actually want people to be
able to come in
and begin tweaking these designs
tweaking the pixar
you know like in a in a blockchain it
would be a literal bifurcation that
occurs
and so or in in code it would be like
you literally
take and you copy the existing code
structure and you put it here and begin
building on top of it are you talking
about like a virtual reality game that
kids would play
partly yeah yeah that's a that's a
that's a very
exciting future in in my um opinion is
some sort of a virtual slash
augmented mixed reality style and so
this helps
explain the pro hard problem of
consciousness because it helps you
reflect on your own qualitative
experiences of
sentience or something like this yeah
okay yeah
all right well so uh
you should get some angel investors and
create we're working on it michael
we we have a lot of plans for 2021
virtual reality company that teaches
kids
how to access their inner consciousness
that could be good
that could be good i can see that um i
mean i'm always looking for some
pragmatic angle of you know
what are we talking about here what
what's why are we even talking about
this
uh you know why is reality
whatever you however you phrase that
initial question okay why do we want to
know
you know if there's some pragmatic
outcome to it
even if it's just the cosmic perspective
changes the way you look at things and
then
then then i'm interested yeah not saying
i'm going to invest just yet but
[Laughter]
i love it because you're right that it
really does
boil down in many ways to a pragmatic
angle of things in
in in a scientific humanistic rational
way and even in a spiritual way it
really does boil down to just
maximizing well-being maximizing
prosperity
maximizing gift achievement into the
world especially for young people
and for young people to sort of in a
sense
become more engaged you know democracy's
not a spectator sport
you know civic engagement is not
something that
the economic machinery should pressure
people out of being able to do
and so to sort of hone in on that from a
young age
is really important not only the nature
of that self-reflection that then gives
children
access to potential self-realization and
self-actualization
but also to just be in a sense a good
citizen in the social fabric itself
whether it be with their family or their
community
the world at large and ultimately that
is what this
process of investing in your own
awareness does
this is another good way to visualize
what the rest of that diagram meant
though why do you need the calculus
oh the integral yeah well the integral
is important because
you you have to have a and
oh there it is and the consciousness is
floating off the globe
into multiple neurons yeah yeah so we
can let's let's pull it let's pull it
out what is that
what are we looking at here so there so
the reason why
the uh the integral is present
is because there's a it's not only a
summation
of the infinitesimal data that is the
human phenomenological experiences that
are happening all 8 billion of them
but it's also the 10 million species on
the planet
as well so it's a summation of that and
so
that whatever that qualia representation
is is summated in there as well and so
that was just a little bit more
complicated to add to it but i wrote
about it in this
i mean is this sort of a like a cosmic
consciousness that the internet's gonna
bring like
as like a a teal heart to chardons zeus
here
is it new sphere yeah news fair
uh you know which is sort of the first
incarnation of that idea
okay so i'll be asking you about the
god head the omega point uh at some
point as well
in a little bit but yeah the reason why
um the brain is present
is because it's a good analogy in this
scenario
because there's we approximate 86
billion neurons
approximately equivalent amount of glial
cells there's
a firing and wiring a synchronization
process
you know two neurons communicating can
be analogous in many ways to
to humans communicating across synapse
it's very interesting
and so in a sense it's like a
a planetary
phenomenological experience that's under
that
that everything is undergoing and then
this is only one
representation of it on we hypothesize
on a on a on a micro like on a scale
invariant level
this is the phenomenological integral
that's happening on planet earth
but then what we hypothesize is not only
in just
these cosmos in this universe but beyond
that as well which we're still we're
still hypothesizing working out but
we think it is yeah i'm not i'm not sure
this is a hypothesis
because a hypothesis is something pretty
specific
you know a lot of your ideas explain
everything
and an idea that explains everything it
tends to explain nothing you know it's
got to be
uh is there some way to get at it what
exactly
are you trying to explain and and what
is the explanation
so we can test it see if it's right or
not yeah the answer to that question
would be the nature of reality
so metaphysics what the nature of
reality is and then
obviously consciousness plays a
fundamental role in that and then
well maybe but not everybody
and so this is where this is what what
what's occurring right now is that
spirituality says
consciousness is fundamental and
physicalism says physicalism materialism
is fundamental
and now you have a massive dissonance
that's occurring when really a synthesis
should be occurring and so that's so
that's what i'm working on
so the nature of reality the synthesis
of science and spirituality
and being
in many ways this is i would say
what we've been looking at is
it's a it's a big part of of what
we've been talking of what the project
is but i think ultimately
this part which is the very first part
of the book
is on levels of perception and it's
trying to get people to see that
the same way that you look at a tree
where a low level of perception is just
some random tree icon the medium level
perceptions you see a little bit more
detail
and then that higher resolution
perception on the right you actually see
the roots
and you see the fruits and you see the
interconnection of of the human
and then when you sort of go and you you
know you draw the same style of
of analogy here with the human you go
low level perceptions just seeing a
human it's a really de
sacralizing perspective dangerous one
and then the medium level perception as
you see a little bit more detail but
then that high level perception on the
right
is where you see the whole suite of
nuance that's actually fused into
into who they are again at a root and
fruit level and then you'll see kind of
where i'm getting at here which is
you know douglas hofsteder thinks that
analogy is a core of cognition which is
very fascinating
and so in this case we're just
analogizing the
the high level tree to the high level
human and we realize that oh yeah
like a tree isn't going to be able to
produce fruits if it has
nutrient deprivation it's the same thing
with a human
a human needs their basic needs to be
met which is why it's plastered all over
the un's sustainable development goals
and that way the human can actually
achieve its unique
gifts into the world and so this analogy
i would say
is uh a top reason as well so along with
metaphysics understanding the nature of
our reality
synthesizing science and spirituality
and meeting basic
needs providing the analogies that give
people the basic
needs to maximize those across the
planet those are i'd say the three
things
and then the other part of that question
was
you know well if it's a framework for a
lot of things
it's really difficult to in a sense be
able to
prove it make hypotheses and actually
you know validate these things
well actually this one doesn't really
need like
i mean a lot of what i've been saying is
already scientifically literate
like it's already scientifically
empirically validated like we don't need
to
like it's obvious that when a child is
deprived of oxygen or water or food or
shelter they're gonna have a traumatic
life right okay cool cool so we're on
the same page there
and then that same graphic that i was
showing you earlier where there's a
cyclical
interchange that happens between the
human and the photosynthesis of the
planet from phytoplankton and trees
that's also scientifically literate and
validated and proven
i mean i don't we are i'm already using
many of the flags
yeah it's a bit like uh james lovelock's
gaia hypothesis you know the earth is
alive
okay it's a metaphor you know meta we
think in metaphors
but what do you mean by alive i mean you
know living organisms are defined by a
certain
way that a planet doesn't really meet
that
definition so again we're you know
there's there's a lot of big words here
big sweeping generalizations massive
metaphors
okay now what now you say well james
lovelock's got a
idea that the earth kind of fueled the
environmental movement
because if you think of all of this
integrated it makes you care
more about destroying the rain forest
and so on okay
yeah that's that's that kind of
metaphorical truth that does have
practical
um applications to how we interact with
each other in the environment say
but is it literally true is the earth
literally alive
no i would say not and and just to be
very very clear here james lovelock has
a specific way of putting these
concepts into a into something that's
digestible for people and understandable
for them
this is different and i think it's
really important to identify that
although there are some similarities
across the different
people that you've been mentioning that
this is also very different in its own
unique ways
and that i'm not coming at it from that
angle
so much as i am coming at it from an
angle of
phenomenology or qualia
so there's a an actual we could say
uh a way to specifically
catalog phenomenology that occurs
and then be able to summate
that phenomenology on a planetary level
as a whole of conscious experience
that's occurring
as on a planetary level so that would be
that would be what i would say in in
contrast to that and there's another
sort of
uh way that i wanted to illustrate
to you something that
could be in sight anyway what what are
we looking at here this oh this is just
hi
this is highlevelperception.com it's uh
the book that
i synthesized so i i wrote this i
synthesized and wrote this
in 2020 from january until october
this is your covid project so this is an
e-book it's just
it's just or it's a web page yeah so i'm
uh i'm actually
uh i i've i published it um about a
month ago
and then i just added a couple like
added about
i put it into 20 graphics and i added
three graphics um in the last a couple
weeks
and then now it's going to be published
uh as a
soft cover hardcover um audible kindle
across all major distributive platforms
before christmas
and so yeah i just worked with an
independent publisher on that so
so i'm a 28 year old author which is
really exciting
and also that i wanted to i wanted to
put
everything that i've learned into a
framework it's kind of important to do
that a lot of
a lot of the time we spend um like a
majority of
our life not knowing what our values are
not knowing where our concepts hang in a
sort of lattice of sorts
and so to at least be able to data
visualize our own
lattice our own framework and then
leverage that to become a more
coherent thinker so that we're not like
you indicate
in much of what you say so that we're
not wrong about most things
most of the time and so i i agree
with that sort of perception about it as
well because you can actually get
more partial truths if you
put things into a framework into a
coherent framework like this
and then sort of continuously you know
and bill gates has talked about this so
much and that's why
you know his quotes at the top of of the
of the author bio i mean i'll just
quickly show you those quotes
but those quotes are things like you
know
you know it's nikola tesla saying be
alone that is the secret of invention be
alone that is when ideas are born and
then bill gates saying build an upstream
framework
then slot the knowledge in and then
there's terence mckenna the cost of
sanity in societies a certain level of
alienation
and then simone de beauvoir says i tore
myself away from the safe comfort of
certainties
through my love for truth and truth
rewarded me yeah and so there's things
like that but again those are very
general like the first one from nikola
tesla
in fact most invention does not come
from being alone well sorry so just
just to be clear yeah so what's going on
with like tesla and spacex right now and
stuff like that is happening with
teams of you know thousands of people so
of course i completely agree
and i'm 100 aligned with that but the
quote against simultaneity is key here
because
there was also a time when it would
require
a profound stroke of genius to occur
in absolute silence whether that be for
like elon musk or whether that actually
be for you know whatever 15 years ago
but then also for all of these great
minds that we sort of think
as you know well what about you know
whoever else of the geniuses that have
lived and died how much time did
did michelangelo spend alone so that he
could make the sistine chapel and statue
of david and pieta for us today and
and that's just one example out of out
of so many
but this this sort of this sort of i
think also helps
illustrate what is in many ways
um relatable in this both the nature of
reality
the synthesis of science and
spirituality meeting basic needs
and then in this case it's something
like you know in this top left corner
you have the subject and their
relationship with the object
and in this case the object is the
smartphone
and so a lot of people on the planet are
having a very
a relationship with a smartphone maybe
up to potentially four billion people
have
uh devices on the planet now and they
have a very object-oriented relationship
with it
and then what happened was you know
that's at the tip of the iceberg and
then once you get a little bit deeper
uh you maybe hit the surface level of of
the iceberg
did you get a chance to watch the social
dilemma i've seen the social you did
yeah
perfect so perfect so what that second
one is trying to illustrate is that
it's basically what the social dilemma
did for tens of millions of people
which made the subject put their
analysis of the situation not on the
object
but on their relationship with the
object on the arrow itself
and so that's really interesting so
that's a slow awakening is realizing the
relationships
and then the next layer down
is when the subject begins investigating
other subjects
and that's most commonly seen through
phenomena like empathy and mirror
neurons and trying to immerse yourself
in the shoes of somebody else's
life experience and states of
phenomenology and eradicate that
suffering and molasses that's in their
way and then allow them to
more easily achieve their their goals
and so maybe you get a little bit of a
taste of some of the thing that i'm
saying with that
when the neuron sees the neuron in the
other
as well so when they actually feel the
self
in the other and then the last one is
sort of the actual
subject investigating itself and
basically what that last one is is when
you
as a subject when if you if you think of
all the phenomenology that you
experience
and then before all of that
phenomenology that you experience
you think about that awareness that is
the very very back it's like the screen
the rupert spira analogy who's one of
the leading non-dual
spiritual teachers on the planet advaita
vedanta he basically just uses the
analogy of a screen
it's just the screen but without any
movie that's playing on it
and then now you turn on the movie and
then there's
oh look at all this these lights these
cameras this conversation
but then if i take the movie off for a
moment i'm just that
awareness i'm just that beingness
and it is a very difficult thing to
learn how to separate
but that that's what we hypothesize as
the nature
of being the nature of what we
believe god is that's why again leo
tolstoy
the kingdom of god is within you it's
not some sort of a of a
person that's bearded in the sky it's
which is a
hilarious uh um misinterpretation
of of of that's actually what many of
the religion tradition says but not the
mystic ones
but the mystic traditions talk about the
kingdom of god within you being that
awareness and that's why rumi also from
the sufi metaphysics said that
you go around from room to room looking
for the diamond necklace that is already
around your neck
and the sufi's also said that everywhere
you look
you see god and that that's another sort
of way of talking about the unity of all
being in existence
so this in many ways is very different
than some of the dirty water that you
kind of
beat a lot which is which is great and
important because it's like the old
codes
that we want to archive and move past
but the water pressure builds up in the
submarine which is very
this is why a lot of people don't want
to investigate their own awareness
a lot of people don't want to
undergo the process of the subject
investigating itself
but some of the greatest fruits come
from that process
okay
so maybe an interesting way of of asking
you a question about that would be
something like do you
identify periods of time of
investigating your own awareness
have you had spiritual experiences like
that no i don't
do that really i mean you know when i'm
out
hiking walking cycling by myself
there's a lot of reflective time uh but
i don't spend a lot of time thinking
about
these kinds of issues i guess because it
doesn't really go anywhere
um i mean it's just sort of it's sort of
so broad and amorphous that
how does this not go anywhere right if
you have the social dilemma that
introduces tens of millions of people to
their subjects relationship with the
object
i don't understand how that does i'm not
even sure what you mean by that
what that means well you know
with what with what occurred it was sort
of you know the subject had been
so engrossed in the object of the cell
phone of the smartphone and all the
different social apps on it
and the asymmetrical data relationship
and the purpose
i mean i watched the film i i wasn't
impressed i
i don't i think there's the alleged
power of social media is greatly
exaggerated these are not nuclear
weapons
uh i mean there was a lot of
self-flagellation by this tristan harris
character and
a few of the others as if you know the
invention of the like button was like
the invention on nuclear weapons like
like he's the equivalent of j robert
oppenheimer
with sin on his hands he's known blood
you know this sort of thing
i think this uh ex i think this treats
humans as
like automata just you know
agents bouncing around in a pinball game
just hopelessly helplessly
under the control of these uh masterful
uh people out there these programmers
and uh
i i'm really not worried about any of
this stuff i'm not
i think it's greatly exaggerated i don't
think we need to break up the tech
companies
um you know i don't think they're you
know determining the outcome of
elections
by based on the algorithm that sends you
one percent more
positive articles about hillary versus
trump or
or whatever most of the research since
the 2016 election for example
summarized nicely in hugo mercier's
latest book
not born yesterday is that most of these
uh attempts to hack the election through
social media
complete waste of time they did next to
nothing in terms of
shifting people's votes and preferences
very few people actually consume
online content that moves them
one direction or the other and not just
politically but i mean
most advertising is a waste of money
most political
advertising is a waste of money
it's it's based on the wrong conception
of
human cognition you know we're not that
gullible we're not that stupid
and you know we're not just a pinball
bouncing around
helplessly under the control of other
people
you know there are influences but
they're not nearly as strong as
we thought that's the latest research
from people that study this
you know where they actually give
subjects put put them in experimental
conditions to see
see what they actually do so i wasn't
impressed with the social media
and i don't think we should fear
facebook and instagram and
google and all this stuff that
everybody's uh concerned about
and um you know anyway that's that's my
thoughts on that
fair but on a macro level the idea
of a subject interfacing with an object
and being so engrossed with an
object that even before
smartphone technology that if the
subject
never makes the inquisitive process
as we turn it off well no i'm not i'm
not even talking about smartphones
anymore i'm just saying in general in
life
because you know we were talking about
this earlier some sort of
like what we're aiming to build in 2021
is a lot of the sort of mixed realities
technologies
that enable young people to see the
pragmatic benefits and what we're
talking about to maximize their
well-being right the pragmatic grounding
which is really important to completely
agree with you
and then if the subject is never
ever being pragmatically grounded
by an investigation into their own
awareness their own
psyche their own conscious experiences
that they have with objects that they
have with other
selves with other subjects if they don't
have that ever that trigger then the
person is going to inevitably walk
around with a box
around their head in a very egoic state
of consciousness
and usually the only time that they'll
break from an egoic state of
consciousness
is when they have a child because when
you have a child
at least for one moment at least
that you feel like you're in service
to someone else that you're serving
you've de-prioritized your ego in
service of someone else now that may
last a year
18 years it may last a little bit of
time
but forever sometimes it lasts forever
well sometimes it does
yeah but that's the thing is that that
just that process
as we've been indicating is just
investigating inward it leads to a lot
of profound
realizations that then catalyze very
important
pragmatic increases in well-being to
myself my family
because the last thing that you want to
do is you want to walk around being a
bag of stress
a bag of anxiety and just
butterfly affecting out anger and
malevolence especially if you're in a
position as a fortune 500 ceo
imagine if we could quantify the current
state of consciousness of the fortune
500 ceos
of congress of the un general assembly
of the 2200 billionaires on the planet
and imagine if we could provide
interventions scientifically literate
ones around fmri eeg
hrv microbiome all these interventions
that could eventually move
the leaders in these positions to more
transcendent states of being that are
beyond the ego
and then how that would butterfly down
through our society
okay do you feel like that's a good idea
do you feel like that's a
bad idea where do you stand on things
like that um i guess the question would
be
what's the problem you're trying to
solve
well maximizing prosperity on the planet
the ceos make too much money
compared to maximizing prosperity on the
planet
yeah yeah yeah that's just well how are
you going to do that with this
well because well because what happens
is when a
let's just let's just take the the
this the ceo of of of of
let's just take jeff bezos for example
that because i also use him in the
example in the book
because the idea is
if we can at least quantify a biometric
data visualization of the person's
phenomenological state of being
and then if we can provide
scientifically literate interventions
into their awakening to catalyze that
what will inevitably happen
is that jeff already i think in many
ways
does have some of these proclivities
which are fantastic
but they'll get ramped up to the next
level and it's
it's very in a sense very so what would
you want him to do
like tomorrow he gets up tomorrow what's
he going to do
well for example let's say remember we
were giving these examples of like
what deepak is doing right now is one
version of what there's a lot of other
quantified
centers that are doing that actually
have even more tech stacks than what
so you're talking about meditate like 30
minutes a day well remember well
i was just going to the tech stacks
first because what we need to do first i
don't know what that is a test
so the tech stack would be the eeg the
fmri the hrv the microbiome analysis all
this type of stuff okay
okay so we go to where the centers are
at that have the tech stack
available to basically get a
a very pure scientific biometric
scan of jeff let's say
in this example all right okay so now we
have a baseline right
this is how science works we have a
baseline of his biometrics
okay of a state of being now what we
want to do is we want to see if we have
a catalog
of states of human development with
people
you know people like john jean piaget
and lawrence kohlberg and
and shirobindo and the mother mural
fossa and so many of these others
that ken wilbur and claire graves and
and don beck and chris cowan have done
they've basically
made a
a scale of human development that goes
from sort of egoic levels of
consciousness to what we could
say as non-dual levels of consciousness
but the general point is where would
this leader fit in this
scale or this map and then that's where
we have had their first scan of their
biometrics now what we do is we provide
the interventions
so now interventions are things like
what you were just listing a moment ago
which is it's maybe some sort of of a
compilation of buffet items there's many
different items to choose from
there's the ones that you were listing
with what you were listing when you were
at deepak's
uh center and then there's you know
there's ones that like the multi-display
association for psychedelic studies maps
is doing around
entheogens and the and the beauty that
antiogens have
on our on our awakening okay let's say
we we do all this with jeff
what is it what is it you want them to
do open more
centers but it's not even it's not even
me it's not even what i
want it's not about me in this case it's
actually about
what is most optimal and healthy
potentially
for civilization which would be if we re
baseline
let's say if jeff undergoes some of
these options on the buffet for a period
of a couple days or so
and then we take another biometric scan
and let's say that
there have there have been the you know
psychotherapists that have been
helping him integrate some of his
profound realizations that he's been
having
especially if he undergo something
really interesting like a heroic dose of
psilocybin
because if if if something like that was
to happen
and the entire ego gets blown out
and it's literally just a state of
of realized full realized
unity level consciousness what happens
is when that
person read baselines especially in such
a position of power
it's inevitable that everything that
they do downstream from there will be
less
self dealing and will be more in service
to others
which a lot of what amazon's doing is
already serviced what would this
translate into like pay raises for
employees or uh discounted on property
more distribution centers it's a great
question
yeah yeah yeah it would probably be
something like
for for for jeff's case it might be
something like
probably the next most impactful thing
that he could do
after a slight increase in his own
awakening
is to then have a significant portion of
his c-level executives
undergo the same process because it's
not a one
what would they do it's not exactly yeah
and so this is what i
just wanted to preface what i was going
to say with that because that's really
important because it's not a one person
comes in with a gold nugget of more
enlightenment and changes everything but
they need the other
c-level people to come in as well and
then slowly have that
trickle in a way okay so then what does
the whole team do after a whole team has
undergone such experiences
well for example
one can't do something
like you know this is why the epa was
put into places you can't just go and
dump toxins into the river
and then expect that to not affect the
hydrological cycle of the planet there's
an interconnectedness of all things
so that means even with what amazon is
doing whether it be the cardboard boxes
or whether it be the distribution
centers or whether it be the automation
or whether it be how the mental health
of the employees
whether it be providing the employees
with some sort of longer term
uh inclusive stakeholding equity
structures to where even the person
that's coming to deliver
the packages at the door right now is
still earning a couple of tokens per day
in the wealth of amazon the equity
wealth of amazon
so there's all different types of
strategies in this case
yeah my friend john mackie calls that
conscious capitalism yeah
he's he's good at we had alexander
mccobin on the program twice yeah we
like him a lot you know
he's the the present of the conscious
capital oh
yeah okay yeah yeah all right sir what
else do you want to talk about because i
have to go pretty soon yeah let's uh
let's see i have uh probably maybe let's
see what else is in here there's a good
there's still a good amount of things
but let's probably wrap
on let's wrap on something that's really
relatable
okay i mean a lot of what we were doing
not fit not metaphysical
but a lot of that was leading to meeting
basic needs and the
synthesis of science spirituality so
let's play around with something for a
moment okay
all right so here we have a a time
okay so the time is
6 46. oh my god i got it i gotta go
okay all right all righty so my stress
hormones are going we're going okay
646.46 so now
my question would be
have you felt the experience
right we talked about simultaneity have
you felt the experience of time
both being of course present in our
biological infinity
in 80 years or so of life but also have
you
have you also felt the realization that
this idea of 646
monday december 14th is completely
symbolically created by us to represent
this yeah you felt that too
yeah okay good good good so then you
felt
illusory time as well well i'm not sure
what you're
what you're after here well i just want
to i just want to say that experience is
like this
where somebody may have felt like the
illusoriness
of time is also profoundly important
because
now think about how pragmatic that is
because when you
feel and realize that you also realize
more and more how i'm not just
limited to a finite eternal
finite existence but i am also beyond
that
and if i can realize something like that
i can be better in my relationships with
my family my friends and beyond that so
there's like a grounded pragmatism
are you stoned no
but you know because i've had
conversations with friends like this and
they're stoned
as said guru says is i'm high on life
it's really i'm just i'm just joking
with you yeah okay but it's important to
have experience like okay but
really the the let's see the okay the
god head this would be probably
my last thought okay okay so the
one of the questions is what is the
telos you know what's the attractor in
mathematics it's called a strange
attractor yeah
what is our complex system of a
civilization evolving towards
and and could it be something like a
like a metaverse like a in this case it
would be like a synthesis
of artificial general intelligence bio
and neurotech with things like the
neuralink things like the
indistinguishable virtual realities that
we may immerse ourselves into
and so if you put all those things
together and call it a metaverse
are we evolving towards something like
that or what is this attraction yeah
well i i think the deeper part of this
is there a telos to the universe i don't
think so
i don't think i don't think we're in
going in any particular direction
inevitably like unfolding laws of nature
or
you know stages of history that kind of
thing that hasn't
proved to be a very um practical or
predictable hypothesis
um you know so i mean that's such a
broad
kind of generalization but i would say
that's the case
i mean like just take moral progress you
know so i wrote a book about this
with very specific things this is what
happened
this person did this and then this group
did that and then we passed this laws
and then
we got to here now what's behind it of
course is this idea
of reducing suffering and equal
treatment under the law and so forth
which is based on this premise that
i'm not special uh so i shouldn't get
special privileges
that you shouldn't also get um okay so
but that could all get reversed there's
nothing there's no law of nature that
says we have to continue doing that
i think it's unlikely we'll go back to
something like slavery or
or no votes for women or anything like
that very unlikely but not impossible
there's nothing
so this is not a law of nature that you
know we have to go in this direction
um in terms of well okay godhead telos
um that you know
very specific things that are done um
you know are dependent on us actively
doing them
so i mean much of your language makes it
sound like there's this sort of cosmic
force or i don't know kind of a
direction to things
you know and use like well this um you
know maybe it would be something like a
global internet metaversion yeah
metaverse well
you know if making predictions about the
future
anything more than like five years out
nobody knows
yeah you know the best for super
forecasters the people that do this for
a living
they're no better than than the monkey
throwing the dart board flipping a coin
rolling the dice um it's just randomness
and and the reason for that is because
uh
you know the historical systems are so
contingent
the further out you go you don't know
what the contingencies are they're going
to push it down here
push it down there i mean as late as the
really 19 late 70s early 80s no one
predicted the internet
i mean you know it was people the new
sphere maybe that was the closest thing
or a few things like that
but you know no one predicted you know
apps would do this and
you know the smartphones and the
facebook and this was all completely
uh new and so to ask well where are we
going to be in a thousand years from now
i don't know you don't either nobody
knows no one can know
and and and and the implications of that
is that we're not moving toward anything
it could go the way that that you
described but probably not
it'll it'll probably be something
completely different you know if we
didn't know
you know here we are in 2020 if we
didn't know 30 years ago
make it 40 years ago this is where we'd
be how can you even ask well what's this
all gonna lead to in a
a century from now a thousand years from
now i mean i don't know
it's fun to think about that's what
science fiction is is all about it's fun
thought experiments are important
to see what we could conceive of but
let's not think of them as predictions
let's just think of them as kind of
thought experiments for fun to see what
they may you know what
fruit they may give us that that you
know that's possible
um you know so i mean at the end of the
moral arc i kind of speculated
you know maybe you know the nation state
will come to an end you know why do we
need nation states
borders are pretty porous already
economically
although that's kind of gone the other
direction for the last few years
economic nationalism but you know maybe
something like the city-state
would return as the center of power the
mayor would be the equivalent of the
of the president or prime minister now
and that
massive power structures like
corporations um
and government agencies would get
smaller and smaller
and that that power would be more uh
diffusely spread out so no one can get
too much power i
i would think that would be a good thing
but again it's not inevitable that that
would happen
and in fact we've seen since i wrote
that book in 2015 we've seen the rise of
of um you know more of autocracies and
and uh uh you know strong men dictators
and things like that
um you know so again i i don't know
and and and nobody does
silly question what is your favorite
food
whatever i'm i'm i'm uh uh eating at the
moment is usually it i'm pretty much an
omnivore
you know i mean i i study diets and try
to avoid too much red meat and things
like that yeah
but it's pretty much whatever you know
what whatever's in front of me
i i i'm on a seafood diet if i see it i
eat it all right that's a funny one
we haven't had that answer on the show
before
seafood i see it i eat it that's a good
one i'm not as bad as homer
simpson you know just eating donuts i do
try to avoid
those kinds of things yeah you take good
care i mean the research on this is
pretty
it's pretty interesting uh marta zaruska
her book growing young
documents all this that um you know
social relationships
having uh living with somebody uh
that you that you actually like to live
with uh you know having friends and
family you know having neighbors that
you talk to
these things uh in terms of mortality
risk
they lower mortality risk more than
exercise and diet
exercise and diet are still important
but even more important
it's you sort of you combine the two of
those exercise and diet together
having a you know a spouse a partner
somebody that
loves you that you love having children
family friends
anything a social network people you
talk to every day
that you know them they know you you
care about them they care about you
and then just expand out from there
neighbors a community that you care
about
um you know that kind of thing that
matters even more than the diet and
exercise
so i really don't worry too much about i
mean i like
cycling a lot so i ride i work out a
couple hours a day but it's
mainly because i enjoy it yep not that
like oh boy i get to live five more
minutes now at the end of my life
something like that uh you know and as
marta points out you know
you don't have to you know get set your
alarm at five in the morning and do
burpees for an hour
and then eat a kale salad for breakfast
you can just sleep in and then
kiss your partner talk to your neighbor
and volunteer for the local
whatever non-profit and that'll do even
more than eating kale
and sweating at six in the morning right
so yeah
yeah if that's what you mean by
spirituality that's
beautiful yeah that's yeah this is it's
been such an
interesting back and forth there's so
much to to try and
and drive into a more
uh in a more synthetic level between
science and spirituality and a less
um for your book i i would i would say
if i was to give any advice as
somebody's written a lot of books
um ask yourself this what's my book
about
what what what question am i trying to
answer what
problem am i trying to solve and the
more specific you can make it the better
you know just just think of the again
the elevator pitch you know the the
salesman at the publisher says well i
gotta pitch this to the bookstores
so that they'll order it what's it about
and if it's if it's like it's about
everything one
uncovering the nature of reality two
synthesizing signs of spirituality and
three
meeting basic needs yeah that's a lot
that's a lot that's that's pretty big
and i mean
it's really interesting that it's only
23 graphics
and it's it's uh maybe
like only a couple um
words a couple paragraphs for each one
of those graphics so it's really short
and it's people have finished it in 30
minutes you should just call it 10 rules
for life
two two less than jordan 20 20 23
graphics
yeah this is i think this is probably
one of the like more
simple ways also to understand the
synthesis of science and spirituality in
many ways well that's a good thing
yeah yeah stuff like this you think
about it like physicalism and
spirituality individuality and
non-dualism
also solo and symphony is another good
way to get careful on the jargon i mean
the average person
no idea what you're talking about it's
it's too up here
like so what what i don't even know what
you're talking about
how does this affect my life well we
spent a good um
almost you know hour i'm just telling
you you know to introduce it to somebody
we did we gave but we gave those simple
breakdowns of
pragmatic applicability throughout the
um
our plus conversation that should
anchor some of these these points in so
yeah i want to i want a one percent
commission on all your sales that's
it michael all right thank you so much
for coming on the show again
super appreciation we were supposed to
do an elbow boom okay yeah thank you
very much
for coming on the program thanks
everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate
it we'd love to hear your thoughts in
the comments below
let us know what you think about the
synthesis of science and spirituality
and how we can bring this more to our
world we'd love to hear from you
also check out michael's links in the
bio below we have a bunch of his links
down there uh everything from his
website also skeptic.com
also all the articles he's run for
scientific american
also his twitter is down there and all
of his books especially his most recent
one
giving the devil is due check those out
and support the artist entrepreneur
spiritual leaders
scientists engineers people building the
future in your communities and around
the world support them help them grow
you can support us simulation our links
are in the bio below
help us flourish as well and go and
build the future everyone manifest your
dreams into the world synthesize science
and spirituality we love you very much
thank you for tuning in
we'll see you soon peace
very good